this interaction started five years ago
when someone tagged us on Twitter and
asked if we're brothers and we do look
alike this is weird there's definitely
some similarities we just took a photo
with bear and we go yes okay who is the
father you are the father
but now we're gonna take your makeup
knowledge to the next level you're gonna
have to answer some questions and
they're easy questions or true or false
questions about makeup and health and
skin care so you should rock this this
shouldn't be a problem for you every
question you get right I'm going to
donate 500 bucks to the charity of your
choice which you have predetermined to
be the LGBT Center in Los Angeles I'm
the inner beauty today he's the other
outer wait that's actually so sweet and
cute I love that we're launching March
and Mandy's gonna help me launch merch
by wearing it trust me I'm a doctor
I love that can you say it I can't even
see it you don't know the catchphrase I
do man you lied to me he told me he
watches the channel and what's the weird
sound that I make pee
[Music]
makeup or fake up true or false you
don't need to wear sunscreen let me
finish okay you're right you don't need
to wear a sunscreen okay if your makeup
has SPF in it I mean I always am down
for a double layerage so I would say
fall still okay that's a good point
you're correct 500 bucks 500 the double
layer thing is a little inaccurate
because it can confuse people okay why
why because it's not additive SPF 15 on
and then make up with SPF 15 it's not
like SP 30 right so it's not added you
have to really make sure so I would say
put on the good quality SPF first and
then whatever your makeup has great it's
fine right right true or false you
should apply your sunscreen before your
makeup true but you actually have to
apply it after as well or after the
timing is done like we can use like a
powder sunscreen a spray sunscreen and
applying it after because the time still
wears out you still have to do it before
and after while you're still wearing it
I actually give you bonus points because
you not only answer to cry directly but
you got the extra part that I was gonna
say but the thing is because I'm a
professional you are a professional
is true or false
wearing makeup is bad for the health of
your skin
he's thinking about it I'll go and say
true because I was like wearing like
Foundation powder things like that it
can clog your pores enough it can't be
ever good so I'm gonna say Joe who else
ew I hate it as long as you're taking it
off what if you're not apply okay I mean
that's wrong you're not following the
direction I'm very competitive that's my
problem like if I tell you if I say you
know is it dangerous to drink water purr
underwater do you drink piranha water
off I don't I could be bad moral of the
story number one man he's wrong number
two
wearing it even often is not problematic
okay good but make sure that you clean
it off to maintain the healthy skin so
that you don't clog your pores true or
false makeup
expires slash goes bad 100 true it
expires because bacteria can get inside
of it
um you know it could be like literally
anything like it's like we can't pump in
mascara you're constantly putting air
bacteria things in the air floating I
don't need to even be a part of this
video
this is not fair well this is like kind
of the opposite of medications right
like over-the-counter medications that
are not life or death can usually be
used after the expiration date yeah but
like the medications that you need for
your life like those need to be on par
got it because the danger of medications
expiring is that they don't become as
effective God they don't like grow
bacteria they don't become bad for you
they're just not useful got it but
makeup can actually be harmful when it
expires not just not useful do I use
experiment because sometimes a hundred
percent okay don't do what Manny does
I'm gonna I'm gonna be honest he's Manny
the bad makeup artist when it comes to
powders they expire way less quickly
than like creams and liquids or anything
that's a little more wet look as fungi
can get in there yeah and start sporing
and they're not the kind of fun guy that
I am
that was that was pretty good actually
you want to promote the tour after that
yeah no I don't because then people are
gonna sell their tickets
designed her makeup is better for your
skin nope false I would say it depends
on the ingredient deck but you can have
really really nice high-end ingredients
and drugstore makeup the same kind of
ingredients that can be found in your
high ends up depending on where the lab
is made a lot of times a lab that makes
let's say Armani can be making stuff
from L'Oreal as well
TV with like the guy with the melons
he's like obsessed with what are you
talking about the guys like I went to
France and I found this melon and if you
put the melon cream on your skin I
really don't I know I literally don't
know what you're talking about there's
melons in France that are apparently
it's unhealthy to sleep with your makeup
on true take that ish off yeah so it
becomes a problem like you said clogging
pores you're smearing all your makeup
all over your pillows yeah but you know
what the biggest scam here is and it's
not a scam let me back up a little bit
maybe it's my words carefully okay this
company approached me to try and sell
silver sheets and you're like these are
antibacterial sheets so you don't get
acne and like this is the most
ridiculous statement ever are you
telling people that if they get these
sheets they no longer need to wash them
it's not like silver kills all bacteria
it just doesn't the bacteria doesn't
Harbor it as readily I love seeing the
little bare hairs flying everywhere
that's what adds flavor to the room and
it did I can taste it literally be
careful if you eat a lot of animal hair
it can cause a bees or this is yeah oh
stomach I I just felt so physically ill
I don't think you understand I literally
felt like a little nauseous true or
false time anti-aging wrinkle creams
actually remove wrinkles
retinol does a good job at like
minimizing wrinkles slightly I would say
true then they don't actually remove
wrinkles they basically encourage cell
turnover to create more collagen and so
then the wrinkles become smaller the
appearance of it gets reduced gotcha
because I feel like what I've used
directly the soul of the wrinkle hangs
around oh God I gotta got it what in the
horcrux not you being like the soul of
the wrinkle true or false Maddie true or
scare me there is no need to wash a
makeup brush if you're the only one who
uses boss why because again bacteria
like it gets nasty and dingy and if
you're using the same brush constantly
that's still touching your face there's
bacteria on your face still going on the
brush it's gonna start it's gonna have
its own little ecosystem in the brush if
you don't brush it you know what's a
good example here you're the only one
who washed it wears your clothes if you
wash them right something I don't even
think about that same for makeup brushes
it's the truth you have to wash them
people with natural oily skin
don't need a moisturize should use
moisturizer true that's a big
misconception a lot of people like oh
I'm oily onion moisturize now you do
maybe your Skin's over producing oil to
compensate for how dry it feels where we
see this happen quite often is on the
scalp or some people are like oh like my
scalp is very oily so that means it's
not dry and actually it could be dry and
it's producing a lot of oil or there's a
lot of oil being produced and then
there's little bacteria that eat it and
then cause inflammation and flakes Etc
so there's all sorts of different
variables here but what I will say is
when you put on a moisturizer you're
helping your skin stay moisturized and
lock in that moisture oil doesn't
necessarily help you do that and you
want to use a moisturizer to prevent
rosacea acne because if you have a
breakage in Your Skin Barrier that's
where I'm like bacteria gets in and all
that stuff true or false the best and
cleanest tool for applying makeup is
your fingers if they're washed I'm
asking true or false oh my gosh you know
what I'm gonna go with true no I'm not
no that's it sorry it depends my brush
you know brushes are right answer but
what if the brush is dirty what if it's
been used yeah but we said the cleanest
are your fingers the cleanest they can
be they can be sometimes what I would do
makeup on people and I had washed my
hands and like I would sometimes like
blend out with my finger because it was
clean yeah but is that the best
or is that what you were doing in a rush
I think I was doing in a rush what no
you're like yeah
true or false you can restore and
continue using mascara after it's dried
up you can you can restore it
man you just said the answer before
listen you can restore it now you're
giving people misinformation no I'm
saying you can restore it you said that
you said I was listening to restore
bacteria you can restore true or false
it's safe to consume a small amount of
lipstick if it gets into your food true
the thing is you're gonna if you go if
you wear lipstick you're gonna
constantly be consuming it every small
amount of it gets into your food how
much is a small amount a decent amount
okay
what the hell does that even literally
mean I'm gonna answer the question
medically then Manny can choose to
accept or not these results I don't
accept medically some lipsticks contain
lead which you do not want to eat and
that could be problematic then you
should be wearing that kind of lipstick
at all period wait well lipsticks
contains what these ingredients
lipsticks contain lead I'm gonna go
ahead and say that was a that that
didn't count well this is your chance to
make up for it true or false another you
said the last little three times safe to
consume a small amount of nail polish if
you nibble on your fingernails
I'm gonna say model that one I would say
it's not safe I feel like nail polish
ingredients are even more intense than
lipstick ingredients you're right I mean
that sounds like very very chemically
harsh good true or false it's unsafe for
children and teens to wear makeup
because of the chemicals on their young
skin I would say it falls so you're
saying it's safe yeah I would say it's
an adult using it like their kids well
they have young skin what does young
skin mean I'm gonna reread the statement
and give them another chance because
he's confused it's unsafe for children
and teens to wear makeup because of the
chemicals on their own skin false I hate
you literally he's like confusing the
shoot out of me dude while children at a
are at a high children and teens are
higher risk of complications with their
skin I'm like oh 12 13. putting on
makeup occasionally and maintaining good
hygiene there shouldn't be a problem
putting on the makeup okay but when I
was saying ethical and moral
considerations aside of course true or
false make up with fewer ingredients
tends to be healthier I would say false
because it depends on the what the
ingredients are tense
tense tens tens tens what the hell are
you what the hell does that mean oh tens
tens I think you're saying ten can I say
it tens across the board so wait read
the question again okay make up with
fewer ingredients tends to be healthier
okay I'll say true it is true yeah to me
why they tend to be healthier is you can
you can't hide a lot of BS when you have
a short ingredient list that's why I
like with Foods you want to eat Whole
Foods because like you know what you're
getting right and it doesn't necessarily
mean if there's a lot of ingredients
automatically bad it just tends to be
easier to understand and tends to be
held tens ten see it's like an English
lesson and makeup
we're all winning if I'm winning you're
winning especially the lgbtq center
because there is one five thousand
dollars no way yeah good job how about
we leave them at the party thought that
they should watch you Glam me up yes on
video right now click here for that
video on my channel
right there click here check that out
and as always stay happy and healthy he
knew the line he watches the end of the
videos but not the beginnings okay
[Music]